BRIAN: LET’S TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO IS TRYING TO OPEN THINGS UP
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS.
THE GOVERNOR ONE OF THE SLOWER
ONES TO SHUT THINGS DOWN IS NOW
ONE OF THE FIRST TO OPEN THINGS
UP.
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER EXPIRES ON
APRIL 30TH AND WE SAW AT
JACKSONVILLE BEACH YESTERDAY FOR
THE MOST PART WHEN THE BEACHES
WERE OPEN FOR TWO SEPARATE
SHIFTS DURING THE DAY IT WENT
PRETTY WELL.
GOVERNOR, WHAT WENT INTO THAT
DECISION WHAT’S NEXT FROM
FLORIDA.
>> WE HAVE GREAT TASK FORCE FOR
PEOPLE ALL OVER.
INDUSTRIES PARTICULARLY SMALL
BUSINESS AND WE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER A LOT OF GREAT IDEAS
FOR WHAT THE NEXT PHASE LOOKS
LIKE IN FLORIDA.
I HAVE GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
DID YOU GO BACK SIX WEEKS.
EVERYBODY, PARTICULARLY IN THE
EXCEL IMMEDIATE SAYING FLORIDA
WAS GOING TO BE WORSE THAN NEW
YORK.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A VERY ELDERLY
POPULATION.
IF YOU LOOK THAT’S NOT TRUE.
NEW YORK, FOR EXAMPLE, HAS 25
TIMES THE NUMBER OF FACULTIES OF
FLORIDA EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
2 MILLION MORE PEOPLE LAST NIGHT
WE HAD 730 PEOPLE STATEWIDE IN
THE ICU.
PEOPLE SAID OUR HOSPITALS ARE
GOING TO BE OVERRUND.
WE HAVE INCREASED HOSPITAL BED
SPACE AND ICU BED SPACE DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO THERE WERE FEWER
BEDS AVAILABLE IN FEBRUARY THAN
THERE ARE NOW.
FLORIDA HAS FLATTENED THE CURVE.
PEOPLE HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
I THINK WE UNDERSTAND THAT CAN
YOU DO BOTH YOU CAN AT THIS
POINT TO FIGHT COVID-19 BUT GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND HAVE
SOCIETY FUNCTION AGAIN.
I NEVER DID DRACONIAN ORDERS
HERE LIKE YOU SEE IN SOME OF
THESE OTHER STATES WHERE DAD
WOULD GET ARRESTED OR GET CITED
FOR TAKING HIS DAUGHTER TO THE
PARK.
THAT DOESN’T WORK.
WE HAVE NEVER DONE THAT WE HAVE